this her moment and her time our new
prime minister arriving in downing
street
in a brief break from the rain the
weather meet in the moment for liz truss
who faces a torrent of tough decisions
and a very grim winter ahead
but like boris johnson before her this
pm upbeat
we shouldn't be daunted by the
challenges we face
as strong as the storm may be
i know that the british people are
stronger
our country was built by people who get
things done
we have huge reserves of talent of
energy and determination
i am confident that together
we can ride out the storm promise him to
pursue three priorities in government
the economy the nhs and the most
immediate issue of all the cost of
living crisis i will deal hands-on with
the energy crisis caused by putin's war
i will take action this week to deal
with energy bills and to secure our
future energy supply i am determined to
deliver
thank you
but her smile can't mask the stormy
outlook she inherits are you daunted by
the task prime minister do you have a
plan
this a pm walking into the toughest
entry in decades
pitching a path for long-term success
but only if she can tackle the immediate
problems at her front door
down to business immediately with her
cabinet emerging early evening a new
team but the problems they face all too
familiar
nobody fails to realize the size of the
problem it is an extraordinary problem
any mp now knows what problems
businesses are facing and individuals
have similarly been facing those
problems are you going to be the sven
sven spend chancellor mr kwateng
a chancellor in kwazii kwatang with very
little option but to spend a foreign
secretary confronting a war in ukraine
and a home secretary with a
controversial immigration plan to settle
this the new health secretary and deputy
prime minister with one of the biggest
winter challenges of all trying to fix a
creaking nhs we've got priorities abcd
ambulances backlogged care
d doctors and dentists and
we're going to work through that and
we'll make sure that we are delivering
for patients
earlier in the day the new prime
minister landed in scotland for her
audience with the queen as these
unprecedented economic times were met
with a breaking constitutional
convention too
liz trusts to balmoral to formally
accept the job this a ceremony not held
outside london for seven decades
mistrust the queen's 15th prime minister
the monarch offering consistency in
these deeply turbulent times
troubles this man today left behind
boris johnson spent the morning partying
with power
[Applause]
stepping out of office but still a
campaigner until the very end
fill in the street with supporters as he
took a part in shot at those who forced
him out this is it folks
the baton will be handed over in what is
unexpectedly turned out to be a relay
race they changed the rules halfway
through but never mind that now
and reminded them of his wins as he
glossed over where he'd gone wrong
winning the biggest majority since 1987
the biggest share of the vote since 1979
delivering brexit
as for what next a classical hinter to
come back like cincinnatus
i am returning to my plow
and i will be offering this government
nothing but the most fervent support
mr johnson likening himself to an
ancient statesman who quit as rome's
leader only to return to power but for
now a promise to support his successor
in the toughest of times i know
that liz
trusts and this compassionate
conservative government will do
everything we can to get people through
this crisis and i will be supporting liz
truss and the new government every step
of the way thank you all very much thank
you and goodbye thank you for the
johnsons this the end of the road
the handover of power this a moment for
liz truss to try to reset a rudderless
government and she's given herself three
huge tasks to grow the economy to tackle
the energy crisis and to try to fix a
break in nhs but she and her top team
know all too well that if she can't sort
out the issue of energy bills soon the
door of opportunity for her with the
public and investors could sharply close
the next few days will be critical on
thursday the new prime minister will
announce a massive energy bailout plan
for families and businesses a package
she hopes will settle this incoming
storm and buy her some time beth rigby
sky news westminster